bien mes chers collègues nous sommes
heureux d'accueillir ce matin Hervé
Berville et secrétaire d'État chargé de
la mer nous vous remercions Monsieur le
Ministre pour votre présence devant
notre commission des affaires
européennes car l'actualité européenne
est riche en ce qui concerne la mer dont
vous êtes chargé au gouvernement et que
vous connaissez intimement pour avoir
grandi et été élu dans les Côtes-d'Armor
la politique de la pêche est
communautarisée depuis 40 ans et le
littoral français est aussi une
frontière extérieure de l'Union
européenne c'est pourquoi les enjeux en
matière de maire sont pour la plupart
d'envergure européenne la pêche d'abord
ces dernières années les pêcheurs
français ont subi l'épuisement de la
ressource le brexit le covid les effets
de la guerre en Ukraine notamment sur le
prix du carburant le gouvernement
propose un plan de sortie de flotte mais
ce n'est pas une panacée non seulement
certains bateaux n'y sont pas éligibles
mais un moyen terme nous sommes inquiets
pour la vie de nos territoires car
derrière les pêcheurs c'est toute une
filière et de nombreux un devis qui sont
en jeu et du Pas-de-Calais je peux
parler du premier port de pêche français
Boulogne en une quinzaine d'années le
port de Boulogne a perdu près de 100
bateaux comment envisagez-vous
d'encourager le maintien de l'activité
comment comptez-vous soutenir la pêche
artisanale comment la protéger de la
scène des mersales est limitée la
présence des grands navires néerlandais
dans la Manche tant d'écrire nous sommes
aussi vigilants en ce qui concerne le
cadre réglementaire européen en matière
de pêche où en sont aujourd'hui les
négociations sur le projet de nouveaux
règlements de contrôle des pêches quel
est l'enjeu pour la France de ce texte
en apparence technique nous
souhaiterions aussi vous entendre sur
l'avenir de la politique commune de la
pêche et la réflexion ouverte par votre
prédécesseur Annick Girardin sur une
gestion des pêches qui intégrerait mieux
la dimension écologique des écosystèmes
en passant d'une approche par espèce à
une approche par territoire maritime
deuxième enjeu de votre portefeuille les
ports les ports français doivent faire
face à la concurrence des autres ports
européens et bientôt des ports francs
annoncés au Royaume-Uni et ils doivent
aussi relever les nouveaux défis de la
transition énergétique comment
envisagez-vous d'accompagner l'évolution
du modèle économique des ports français
quelles actions mènent le gouvernement
pour renforcer leur accrit leur activité
pardon et accroître leur part de marché
nous souhaitons aussi échanger avec vous
au sujet des perspectives ouvertes par
les mutations en cours en matière
d'approvisionnement énergétique du
continent puisque cette
approvisionnement va principalement
devenir maritime à ce sujet pouvez-vous
nous dire où en est le projet
d'installation d'un terminal métallier
flottant dans le port du Havre
concernant l'éolien en mer le dispositif
de planification prévue par le texte sur
les EnR a été généralisée à l'ensemble
des façades maritimes à l'initiative du
Sénat dans quelle mesure votre
secretaria d'État sera-t-il associé à
l'identification des zones propices à
l'implantation de parc éolien en mer
comment concilier le développement de
ses parts et la protection des fonds
marins qui sont déjà menacés par la
pollution liée à l'activité humaine
l’exemple du parquet éolien en baie de
Saint-Brieuc est à cet égard édifiant un
dernier mot concernant les suites du
brexit considérez-vous régler la
question de l'accès de nos pécheurs aux
eaux anglaises y compris dans les îles
Anglo-Normandes qu'elle a été l'impact
pour nos pécheurs de la nouvelle
réglementation britannique en vigueur
depuis un an concernant la taille des
filets et son application en mer
s'agissant de la réserve d'ajustement de
brexit nous serions intéressés de savoir
quel soutien finalement été apporté à la
filière pêche pourriez-vous aussi nous
indiquer les pistes envisagées pour
mettre un terme au dumping social sur le
transmanche au-delà d'une simple charte
d'engagement volontaire que vous avez
présenté récemment au ministère ce sera
l'occasion
de faire le point de l'adhésion à cette
charte enfin nous aurions souhaité
évoqué la gestion franco-britannique de
la frontière européenne que constitue la
Manche nous ne pouvons pas laisser
grossir encore le flux des migrants qui
traverse cette mer de manière illégale
et quelles sont les perspectives en la
matière je pose je pense qu'en
interministériel vous en discutez
fréquemment voilà Monsieur le Ministre
un flux de question auquel vous pourrez
répondre peut-être directement mais de
toute façon nous sommes appelés à nous
revoir ou à nous écrire
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
cher Jean-François merci mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et les scènes
tristes de votre audition je suis très
heureux d'être ici je me permets
puisqu'on est encore au tout début
février de vous souhaiter à toutes et à
tous mes meilleurs vœux à vous à tous
vos proches et puis au sénateur et cette
belle institution que vous représentez
beaucoup de succès de réussite
collectives personnelles et je crois
beaucoup de belles actions et de beaux
projets pour le monde maritime alors je
suis très heureux d'être ici c'est ma
première édition audition devant la
commission des affaires européennes du
Sénat parce que je crois que l'année
2023 est pleine de à la fois de risque
pour le monde maritime vous l'avez
évoqué mais aussi je crois plein de
facteurs d'optimisme parce que on voit
partout dans les lycées maritimes quand
je l'occasion de me déplacer dans vos
territoires aussi des jeunes qui ont
envie de rentrer dans le métier marin
que aussi nous avons la chance d'avoir
le deuxième espace maritime au monde et
donc c'est une opportunité c'est aussi
une responsabilité et je le crois que
dans l'économie dans laquelle nous
vivons nous sommes et vous l'avez évoqué
aussi avec 80% du commerce qui se fait
sur l'espace maritime je crois que les
enjeux qui sont devant nous vont nous
permettre et la manière dont on va les
appréhender notamment en
interministériel et j'y reviendrai aussi
sur tous les les sujets que vous avez
évoqués nous permettra à la fois de
faire face et de renforcer la
souveraineté économique et je sais ici
que au Sénat c'est un enjeu un sujet
prioritaire et en même temps de lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique et donc
la mer est au corps de ces enjeux et
donc cette année 2023 comme en 2022 je
crois que la stabilité est au fond un
principe qui doit nous guider nous
aurons j'aurais trois priorités la
protection des océans et de la
biodiversité marine parce que notamment
pour nos pécheurs c'est aussi le gage de
pouvoir continuer à exercer leur métier
parce qu'il faut de la ressource pour
continuer et bien évidemment à pouvoir
pêcher deuxième élément c'est
développer l'économie maritime et
soutenir nos modèles de pêche et donc ça
nous continuerons à soutenir aussi la
spécificité au fond des façades
maritimes françaises et le troisième
plan la troisième priorité c'est la
planification en mer avec les enjeux que
vous avez évoqué sur notamment l'éolien
en mer mais aussi les zones de
protection forte bref des enjeux qui
sont au cœur de nos territoire pour
répondre peut-être sur les sujets de
pestes qui sont des sujets
fondamentalement européens vous dire que
au cours de l'année qui s'est écoulé
nous avons eu à faire face à un certain
nombre d'urgence la première c'était
pour nos pécheurs et bien la question du
carburant puisque nous avons tous connu
nous a tous vu l'augmentation massive et
assez brutale du coup du carburant qui
est un élément important dans
la structuration la viabilité économique
de nos activités et de nos une
entreprise de pêche et donc nous sommes
battus au niveau européen pour faire en
sorte que à la fois nous augmentions le
plafond d'être carburant possible pour
les pêcheurs quand je suis arrivé en
juillet elle était de 65000 euros les
aides disponibles pour les pêcheurs nous
avons monté une première fois à 105000 €
et nous sommes maintenant à 330 000 €.
le pays la France pardon et le pays qui
s'est battu et qui a obtenu d'avoir
cette augmentation du plafond pour
justement faire face et bien la
difficulté des pêcheurs et pour qu'ils
puissent continuer d'aller en mer et
pour qu'ils puissent continuer et bien
de participer à la souveraineté
alimentaire et qui est pas un
effondrement de la filière ensuite nous
avons aussi obtenu la prolongation du
dispositif puisque il devait s'arrêter
d'abord en juillet il a été prolongé
jusqu'en septembre à hauteur de 35
centimes et ensuite nous l'avons
prolongé jusque en février de cette
année le 15 février et nous travaillons
déjà avec toutes les parties prenantes
avec les acteurs avec les pêcheurs pour
et bien même s'il y aura une réduction
dans le périmètre à continuer de
soutenir nos pêcheurs parce que nous
nous souhaitons pas être je ne souhaite
pas laisser des pêcheurs sans solution
et nous avons besoin de les aider à
faire face à l'inflation donc c'était la
première urgence c'est une enveloppe qui
est conséquente puisque c'est plus de 50
millions d'euros qui ont été alloués qui
ont été fléchés sur la question de
l'aide carburant je crois que c'est là
le gage de notre volonté de faire de la
pêche un enjeu majeur pour la
souveraineté économique de nos pays
ensuite il y avait une deuxième urgence
et vous l'avez évoqué qui était au fond
de faire face de manière responsable de
manière équitable sur les territoires
aux conséquences du brexit la réalité
c'est que personne n'a décidé le brexit
ni les pêcheurs ni le gouvernement
français la réalité c'est que un quart
de de la pêche française se faisait dans
les eaux britanniques et donc à la suite
de la sortie du Royaume-Uni de l'espace
européen
nous avons à la demande des pêcheurs
réfléchi à partir de 2021 un plan
d'abord de sortie de flotte que moi j'ai
souhaité être un plan d'accompagnement
individuel c'est à dire qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'avoir un plan sectoriel qui vise à
sortir beaucoup de bateaux mais c'est un
plan qui vise à accompagner
individuellement les situations
difficiles des pêcheurs et donc nous
avons travaillé en 2022 avec les
pêcheurs sur la définition des critères
qui seraient éligibles pour pouvoir
bénéficier de ce plan d'accompagnement
individuel et puis nous avons travaillé
à je crois trois principes 1 il ne faut
pas que ce plan déstabilise les
territoires déstabilisent l'économie
locale déstabilise par exemple vous
l'avez évoqué monsieur le Président le
port de Boulogne parce que quand il y a
un navire qui sort ça peut et bien avoir
des conséquences sur la filière avale et
notamment sur les entreprises de mariage
le deuxième principe qui était le bien
c'est de faire en sorte et bien qu'il y
ait ça maintient une capacité de pêche
et donc notamment dans la question des
quotas vous savez qu'il y a 70% des
quotas qui retournent à l'organisation
de producteur 30% au niveau national et
bien que tout ça soit fait de manière
équitable soit redistribuée pour
maintenir cette capacité de pêche parce
que nous apportons déjà et il y a eu ici
un excellent rappeur d'un sénateur
rapport d'un sénateur pardon qui a été
effectué qui disait que nous nous
importons plus de 80% de nos produits de
la mer je crois que nous ne pouvons pas
nous payer le luxe d'augmenter ce
chiffre est justement l'idée c'est
d'installer de nouveaux marins
d'installer des jeunes et donc d'avoir
ses capacités de pêche devant nous et
donc nous avons et j'ai été très ferme
très strict sur le sujet il y a 65
millions d'euros il n'y aura pas un euro
de plus puisque je crois que ce que nous
souhaitons c'est faire face aux
situations individuelles et ce n'est pas
d'avoir comme il y a un an un an et demi
c'était aussi dans l'air un plan massif
de 100 millions d'euros qui aurait
déstabilisé la filière et je vous
remercie euh monsieur le Président de
m'avoir alerté sur des situations
individuelles de m'avoir alerté aussi
sur la nécessité de regarder dans le
cadre de la procédure qui a été convenu
avec les pêcheurs toutes les situations
ça sera fait dans les hauts de France
comme dans le Finistère donc ça c'était
l'urgence que nous avions aussi à
traiter avec ce plan d'accompagnement
individuel qui je le croise je me
permets ici de les remercier a été
vraiment co-construit avec les pêcheurs
et vraiment suivi de manière la plus
précise possible par la DGA la Direction
Générale des Affaires maritimes de la
pêche et de la culture avec le directeur
qui est ici présent aujourd'hui ensuite
nous sommes battus vous le savez
monsieur le Président pour au fond faire
en sorte d'avoir ses capacités de pêche
avec notamment la la le Conseil européen
des tac ecotas vous le savez c'est
chaque fin d'année en décembre c'est
cette réunion des ministres des pêches
européennes et qui vise au fond à
répartir les possibilités de pêche entre
entre les pays je me suis battu et merci
beaucoup du soutien qui a été apporté
aussi par la représentation nationale
pour faire en sorte de préserver les
intérêts français préserver les intérêts
des pêcheurs français partout sur toutes
les façades maritimes j'en reviendrai
pas ici de manière exhaustive sur
toute les batailles et toutes les
espèces sur lequel nous avons négocié
j'ai ici un tableau que je pourrais vous
faire parvenir mais je crois pouvoir
dire que pour la première fois depuis
très longtemps nous avons partout
maintenu nos intérêts et nous l'avons
fait avec trois principes 1 reconnaître
les efforts fournis par les pêcheurs
français parce que trop souvent les
pêcheurs fournissaient des efforts et on
leur disait vous avez pas le droit de
pêcher plus alors que la ressource était
en augmentation et donc si je prends des
exemples
comme le bar sud ou il devait y avoir
une baisse de 24
nous avons obtenu dans la négociation et
bien qu'il y a une augmentation de
capacités de pêche à 2500 tonnes nous
avons aussi tenu un deuxième principe
c'est au fond respecter la
différenciation des territoires
respectés des règles qui soient adaptées
aux différents littoraux nous l'avons
fait notamment sur Languille je sais que
c'est un sujet qui était très important
pour beaucoup de sénateurs et donc là
aussi il y avait une règle qui était
prévue par la Commission européenne au
fond c'est une interdiction de six mois
qui aurait été il faut se dire la mort
de la pêche à l'anguille partout sur un
territoire nous sommes battus et je
remercie vraiment ici les organisations
professionnelles et les pêcheurs pour
faire en sorte et bien d'adapter ses
règles aux réalités des territoires et
surtout maintenir la pêche à l'anguille
qui fait partie de la vitalité
économique des différents littoraux et
qui fait partie aussi du patrimoine et
de l'identité de l'économie et de la
pêche française et donc nous avons
obtenu contre l'Atlantique la
Méditerranée on adapte pas exactement
les mêmes règles mais je crois que en la
matière nous devons aller plus loin
parce que nous ne pouvons pas nous
satisfaire que les règles et les quotas
les TACs et les quotas soient définis
comme ça en décembre et qui ne donne pas
de visibilité à nos amis pêcheurs qui
peut au fond
estimer comme viable et comme une
méthode de travail attractive pour nos
pêcheurs de déterminer au 15 décembre
pour le 1er janvier ce que les pêcheurs
ce qu'une entreprise pourrait être en
capacité de pêcher et donc ce que sera
sa visibilité économique et donc nous
nous battons pour la plurianité des
quotas je sais que c'est quelque chose
qui est porté aussi ici au Sénat pour au
fond dire qu'il faut donner la
visibilité de la prévisibilité aux
pêcheurs pour la première fois au
Conseil européen il y a eu au fond la
reconnaissance l'acceptation de
commencer à travailler sur un certain
nombre d'espèces à la plus réanialité
des quotas ça fonctionne puisque nous le
faisons notamment sur d'autres espèces
et donc nous devons nous engager pousser
la commission convaincre les autres pays
partenaires d'aller sur la plus régné
annualité des quotas c'est comme ça
qu'on permettra d'attirer des jeunes
dans le métier donner de la visibilité
et renforcer la souveraineté alimentaire
de notre pays en ce qui concerne le
sujet de la pêche vous l'avez posé comme
question monsieur le Président comment
attirer des jeunes comment faire en
sorte que la pêche continuait à être un
élément fort de notre économie ça
passera par au moins trois domaines le
premier c'est d'investir de continuer à
investir dans la formation maritime dans
les lycées maritimes nous avons
restructuré le réseau des lycées
maritimes pour leur donner plus de force
nous avons augmenté les financements
nous avons un objectif de doubler le
nombre d'élèves officiers formés
notamment dans un certain nombre
d'écoles l'idée étant de rendre ces
métiers attractifs et d'avoir des corps
de jeunes qui viennent
s'installer dans le métier le deuxième
c'est lancer la décarbonation de des
navires de pêche
toutes les crises de la pêche sont des
crises qui sont liées au coût du
carburant et donc comme dans tous les
autres secteurs il faut lancer cette
belle aventure industrielle territoriale
qui est celle de la décarbonation nous
avons initié un travail avec un appel à
projet de 6 millions d'euros sur la
décarbonation des navires de pêche mais
vous le savez dans le cadre de
l'Initiative france-mère 2030 nous
allons investir 300 millions d'euros
pour la décarbonation de l'économie
maritime qui inclura bien évidemment les
entreprises de la pêche et l'ambition
c'est de vraiment d'avoir une feuille de
route de la décarbonation qui est portée
par le ministère en travaillant avec
bien évidemment les chantiers navals les
constructeurs les architectes toute la
filière la filière aussi de la
déconstruction pour et bien le plus
rapidement possible déployer des navires
qui sont des carbonés je crois que c'est
ce que demande également les plus jeunes
qui rentrent dans le métier parce qu'il
voit bien aussi qu'on ne peut plus être
dépendant autant des énergies fossiles
c'est ce qu'on travaille avec les
puisque s'il y a des navires décarbonés
il faut des installations portuaires qui
permettent justement et bien d'avoir
cette décarbonation et c'est tout le
sens de la réunion qui s'est tenu entre
les différents acteurs portuaires pour
la première fois grand port des
centralisé avec le ministre Clément
Beaune pour justement déployer la
feuille de route la stratégie nationale
portuaire avec notamment je crois des
des infections qu'il faudra faire sur
le zan pour permettre justement
l'installation de production énergétique
des carbonée nous aurons une deuxième
réunion pour la stratégie nationale
portuaire et un certain nombre d'entre
vous ont participé dans vos territoires
il me semble en mars pour continuer à
déployer les investissements déployer la
stratégie l'idée étant que les ports
décentralisés participent aussi à cette
aventure de la décarbonation et à cette
aventure aussi de l'éolien en mer et que
on fond la décarbonation irrigue tous
les territoires et que ce soit pas
simplement et bien euh
soit pas simplement
identifiés dans les grands ports d'État
et puis le troisième élément pour
attirer des jeunes dans le métier et
renforcer la souveraineté alimentaire de
notre pays c'est je crois la question de
la planification en mer vous l'avez
évoqué nous avons un espace maritime qui
doit faire face à une multiplication des
usages l'éolien en mer les zones de
protection de fortes les aires marines
protégées et la nécessité d'avoir des
activités économiques et donc tout
l'enjeu qui est devant nous avec
notamment la stratégie nationale de la
mère et du littorale dans le cadre du
Conseil national de la mairie littorale
c'est de justement travailler
à cet exercice de planification et de
définir des zones où il devra y avoir de
l'activité économique et des pêcheurs
qui continuent et bien à
participer à la souveraineté alimentaire
de notre pays des zones qui devront être
plus protégées parce que je crois que la
protection des océans la protection de
la biodiversité c'est aussi je crois un
facteur important pour la tractivité
d'un certain nombre de territoires et
c'est ce que vous demandez ce que nos
concitoyens demandent dans le cadre de
la lutte contre le changement climatique
et également de la préservation de la
biodiversité et il nous faudra définir
dans ce cadre là aussi les zones
propices en 2023 il y aura des
macrosones pour le développement
d'éolien en mer et en 2024 nous aurons
les zones précises de développement des
éoliennes amères vous savez que nous
avons un objectif notamment d'ici
50 de 40 GW c'est à dire une
cinquantaine de parcs c'est un travail
qui sera difficile c'est un travail qui
sera
comment dire le plus
le plus c'est même pas le plus rigoureux
mais c'est un travail qui sera fait
d'abord au niveau
national ensuite qui sera déployé par
façade maritime et je vous remercie des
modifications et des propositions qui
ont été faites dans le cadre de la loi
ENR puisqu'elle permettent d'avoir un
débat unique et au fond d'avoir une
vision la plus globale possible de ce
que doit être la planification en mer et
nous le ferons
avec l'ambition d'avoir des zones de
pêche qui sont préservées d'atteindre
notre objectif de 10% de zone de
protection forte sur le littoral et de
tenir les ambitions sur la transition
énergétique parce que c'est là aussi un
gage pour notre souveraineté énergétique
et donc pour la souveraineté économique
de notre pays et nous le ferons bien
évidemment en pleine concertation avec
les parlements de la mer et vous avez
été l'initiateur d'un très beau
Parlement de la mer parce que je crois
que c'est là aussi où se vit la
démocratie maritime voilà mesdames et
messieurs sénateurs ce que je voulais
vous dire en introduction peut-être sur
les différents sujets
seront évoqués également par les
questions
de vos collègues mais je reviendrai bien
évidemment sur le dumping social je
reviendrai sur
les autorisations de pêche dans les îles
normandes mais j'imagine que ça
reviendra peut-être dans les questions
en tout cas vous dire que l'ambition du
gouvernement l'ambition du secrétaire à
la mer elle est intacte pour renforcer
la souveraineté alimentaire de nos pays
pour faire face aux urgences de
l'activité de pêche c'est à dire le
gasoil la question des licences la
gestion de l'impact du brexit et que dès
cette année et d'ailleurs depuis juillet
nous travaillons a aussi construire la
filière de demain contrat stratégique de
filière décarbonation investissement
dans les ports et planification en mer
qui donnera de la visibilité à tous les
et qui nous permettra d'avoir encore
beaucoup de pêcheurs qui s'installent
partout sur nos magnifiques littoraux
merci
merci monsieur le ministre nous avons
quelques gestions mais au préalable et
peut-être répondre et vous lors de des
réponses aux autres sénateurs je
voudrais avoir quelques précisions sur
la qualité de l'investissement et sur la
façon dont l'État peut investir dans les
lycées puisque alors peut-être que tous
les lycées maritimes ne sont pas sous
l'égide d'investissement des régions
mais en fait l'essentiel de
l'investissement sont les régions qui
les font sur les sur les lycées donc je
voudrais je voudrais savoir comment vous
quand vous dites l'État va investir dans
ses lycées c'est dans quel dans quelles
circonstances il peut le faire et
comment il peut le faire
un point aussi je vous rejoins
pleinement sur la planification
Eric Banel le sait parce que en 2014
puisque la directive date de 2014 j'ai
été l'un des premiers élus du littoral à
voir cette directive arriver et nous
sommes aujourd'hui en 2023 et on
commence à reparler de planification 9
ans après que cette directive soit soit
produit donc ça veut dire que on a eu
une certaine inertie sur le sujet
inertie qui n'a pas été sans créer des
problèmes puisque aujourd'hui l'usage de
la mer redevient difficile parce qu'il
est appréhendé pleinement
notamment sur sur l'éolien et peut-être
pourrait vous nous dire aussi et nous
faire le point sur sur quelques parcs
aujourd'hui qui défraient la chronique
et en tout cas qui suscite les
contestations je pense à Saint-Brieuc je
pense au parc qui sont qui sont prévus
notamment manche en manchestre mer du
Nord
un point aussi je le regrette monsieur
le ministre ça a été justement sur sur
les parc éoliens et peut-être
l'association qu'on a dans la
planification avec les zones de
protection forte
les zones de protection forte ne seront
pas sans conséquence de toute façon sur
la planification et sur la façon dont
les marins et pêcheurs en particulier
vont pouvoir appréhender leurs zones de
pêche on risque d'avoir je pense encore
là des conflits d'usage et des
discussions fortes sur le sujet mais une
me revient à l'esprit c'est que
l'association que vous connaissez très
bien que j'ai présidé pendant de
nombreuses années avait défendu que
l'installation des parc éoliens en zone
économique exclusive aller susciter
forcément la création d'une nouvelle
fiscalité puisqu'elle n'existait pas et
moi je pensais que bon pourcentage de la
fiscalité en ze qui était nouvelle à
créer aurait pu bénéficier aux
collectivités notamment pour régler en
particulier leurs problèmes
d'érosion du trait de côte de recul du
trait de côte voire même quand il y a un
choix d'aménagement du territoire de
résilience sur ces territoires ça n'a
pas été le cas et je pense que
[Musique]
il arrive de faire des erreurs
stratégiques mais je pense que c'est une
erreur stratégique et je voulais
peut-être si vous êtes en mesure
d'apporter des éléments là-dessus que
vous nous les donniez parce que je pense
que ça peut avoir des incidences très
fortes sur le futur on n'a pas parlé du
transforme je me suis le ministre je
vous avais interrogé là-dessus aussi
pour savoir où en était l'état et
l'avancée de la convention que vous
aviez proposé de la charte que vous
aviez proposé vous voyez gentiment
invité au ministère pour pour la
discussion avec les opérateurs de
transmanche
et je voulais savoir si elle faisait son
chemin et si les quelques réticences
qu'on avait pu entendre au ministère de
la part d'opérateurs pouvaient être
pouvait être corrigé voilà
non peut-être parce que d'autres
questions viendront sur le même sujet
garde garder ça à l'esprit
[Musique]
Elisa on va les prendre par trois donc
madame Jourdain madame de Sidrac et
monsieur
le président
monsieur le ministre
j'ai à voir donc
de votre point de vue donc
votre sentiment et du moins le plan
d'action que vous souhaitez avoir par
rapport à nos régions ultra
périphériques je vais donc parler de
l'outre-mer puisque c'est outre-mer et
souvent fragilisée que ce soit ces zones
économiques exclusives donc sont
beaucoup plus fragiles donc chez eux
lorsqu'il y a projet c'est toujours
beaucoup plus compliqué alors je
souhaiterais savoir sur le plan européen
on a le Green Deal dont on parle
beaucoup mais le Plan Bleu a quand un
Plan Bleu quel est votre positionnement
par rapport à ça ensuite un focus
beaucoup plus précis
surtout ce qui est donc le
lancement qui a été annoncé en février
2002 2022 pardon du plan national de
réception des décharges littorales
présentant des risques de relargage des
déchets en mer alors nous avons commis
tout récemment avec ma collègue Viviane
Mallet au niveau de la délégation donc
outre-mer donc du Sénat un
donc
rapport sur les déchets dans les régions
ultra périphériques et nous avons donc
identifier
55 décharges littorales à risque donc 14
sont situés dans les dromes 4 en
Guadeloupe 6 ans Martinique une en
Guyane et trois à la Réunion un premier
chantier de traitement devant démarrer à
Lans charpentier en Martinique le projet
porté par le PCI du Cap Nord et
l'objectif est de toutes les résor 70
ans alors pour nous être rendu sur place
ce n'est pas un petit sujet parce que
c'est des charges qui sont donc
vraiment donc qui plonge dans la mer
sont donc porteuses de pollution donc
nos fonds donc marin et se doivent donc
de d'être dans un plan je dirais très
rapide résorbé donc outre ce sujet qui
est un sujet très très prégnant
ce projet de résorption des anciennes
décharges littorales se posent la
question donc beaucoup plus générale par
rapport à ces départements région ultra
périphériques du traitement que nous
souhaitons leur apporter si nous les
mettons au cœur de nos problématiques
donc de
général d'un plat en global ou si nous
acceptons de d'avoir un plan finalement
d'accompagnement plus approfondi pour
elle parce que s'il n'est pas possible
il y a des rattrapages dans tous les
domaines il faut que la vigilance soit
au rendez-vous et notamment en matière
de contrat lorsque il y a un contrat qui
paraît donc tout à fait favorable à la
France dans certains domaines et qui
sont qui qui est porté par l'Union
européenne il faut faire attention que
ça ne mette pas en certaines filières
économiques de ces régions ultra
périphériques ici sur cette dans cette
commission des affaires européennes il y
a quelques années nous avions donc plus
des jouets les effets pervers d'un
accord avec le Vietnam qui m'était
complètement en péril la filière du
sucre roux à la Réunion parce que nous
les contrats prévoyaient de tels
acquisitions de de sucre roux notamment
que ça mettait en péril tous les efforts
que nous avions fait pour contribuer au
développement économique donc de cette
de ces filières dans nos propres
départements voilà monsieur le ministre
mais je souhaitais ne pas oublier ces
régions là parce que souvent elles sont
absentes des discours les plus officiels
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Ministre d'être parmi nous
ce matin j'avais deux questions qui
n'ont peut-être pas un lien direct mais
qui sont j'ai envie de dire qui ont un
point dénominateur commun que vous avez
rappelé dans vos propos liminaires à
savoir que la France a un des espaces
maritimes les plus grands du monde et à
ce titre là nous avons donc des vrais
sujets autour de la mer et c'est aussi
grâce à cet espace maritime français que
l'Union européenne a aussi un espace
maritime grand donc à partir de là
j'aurais souhaité avoir quel est votre
sentiment sur la pêche que pratique la
Chine en haute mer à la pêche illicite
évidemment c'est elle que je pense
puisque nous savons que les États-Unis
ont une approche plutôt de sanctions
alors que l'Union européenne résonne
plutôt en partenariat je fais référence
aux partenariat bleu les réunions tous
les tous les enfin deux fois par an je
crois sauf erreur de ma part donc
j'aurais souhaitez avoir votre sentiment
sur la les deux méthodes les deux les
deux approches que nous avons vis-à-vis
de cette pêche en haute mer et notamment
comment vous travaillez peut-être de
concert avec notre ministre notre
secrétaire d'État des affaires
européennes sur un sujet qui quand même
touche éminemment l'Europe sur cette
pêche illicites et le deuxième sujet est
également porte que dans la continuité
de la question de ma collègue Gisèle
Jourdas sur les déchets en outre-mer là
encore nous sommes nous sommes l'Union
européenne malgré l'éloignement que l'on
peut avoir vis-à-vis du continent nous
sommes en Rupe or nous savons que
l'exutoire de nos déchets ultramarins
n'est pas aisé puisque nous devons pour
toutes les raisons réglementaires et de
normes les rapatriés en métropole cela
nous pose énormément de questions cela
nous pose un certain nombre de de
difficultés notamment sur nous
l'écosystème ultramarin donc je
souhaitais là encore monsieur le
ministre monsieur le secrétaire d'État
que vous nous éclairiez sur la manière
dont vous travaillez avec notre ministre
délégué aux autres mers et Madame
Laurence Boone parce que il me semble
que la voix de la France doit être
portée à ces différents échelles et moi
j'avais déjà
parlé de ces sujets avec Monsieur
karenko votre collègue mais je
souhaitais savoir si il y a une
concertation interministérielle sur des
sujets éminemment important à la fois
économique à la fois écologique je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le Président oui monsieur
le ministre il se trouve que j'étais
rapporteur de la convention entre la
Grande-Bretagne et la France sur le
transmence chez la sécurité pour
notamment les futurs jeux olympiques 15
millions de passagers par an c'est quand
même pas un point de de détail à ma
connaissance d'ailleurs les deux textes
ont été votés dans les mêmes termes dans
les deux assemblées donc ça devrait pas
poser de problème mais ma question n'est
pas celle-là au cours de mon rapport
j'ai rencontré un certain nombre
d'opérateurs sur la manche je suis élu
du Calvados donc un département
directement concerné par ces sujets et
un grand nombre d'opérateurs m'ont fait
part de de leur inquiétude de leur souci
sur une asymétrie une inégalité de
traitement entre les ports d'État et les
autres ports quant à l'armement
concernant les fonctions régaliennes de
l'État c'est à dire en fait les
fonctions de de contrôle notamment
contrôle d'identité et contrôle
vétérinaire il semblerait que les ports
qui ne soient pas des ports d'État et
qui ont des terminaux transmence soit
sous dotés je souhaitais attirer votre
attention sur ce point
comme ministre pour pas que ça fasse un
trou
très bien merci beaucoup à toutes et à
tous peut-être en commençant par pour
vous monsieur le Président sur les
différents sujets sur les lycées
maritimes il y a plein de de voix et
moyen et surtout il y a plein d'actions
qui sont développées par l'État d'abord
c'est sur la question bien évidemment
des diplômes sur lesquels on travaille
ardemment pour justement rendre les
diplômes encore plus attractifs les
passerelles plus fortes et notamment
j'ai lancé une réforme des BTS pour
justement permettre la diplomation au
niveau officier dans les lycées
maritimes premier point deuxième point
l'État à travers le plan de relance a
financer des investissements dans les
lycées maritimes on est je crois tout le
contrôle de
du directeur général d'informatique mais
à peu près 10 millions d'euros notamment
d'un navire écoles j'ai eu l'occasion
d'aller aussi à la Réunion et merci
madame la sénatrice vous avez tout à
fait raison pas évoqué j'ai évoqué
aucune région en particulier mais vous
avez raison que de pointer que dans le
sujet maritime bien évidemment les
outre-mer sont centrales parce que la
France au fond comme disait très bien
Christian Buchet est une archipel
et et donc nous investissons aussi dans
le cadre du plan de relance nous
investissons aussi dans les lycée à
travers l'initiative portée par les
régions donc du fondateur maritime 15
millions d'euros chaque année ou là
aussi nous investissions dans la
formation et puis nous allons lancer une
campagne sur l'attractivité des métiers
de la mer cette année nous avons déjà
investi 2 millions d'euros de manière
générale pour renforcer l'attractivité
de la mer mais des métiers de la mer
pardon mais nous allons là aussi
renforcer cette campagne de promotion
donc l'État et les régions les
collectivités et les administrations
centrales travaillent en pleine
intelligence pour faire en sorte que le
maximum de jeunes nous sommes dans la
période là avec parcoursup qui viennent
dans ces filières sur le sujet vous
l'avez évoqué des licences jersey gardez
les Aigles en normandes j'ai eu
l'occasion d'avoir le ministre
d'affaires étrangères avec justement
Laurence Boone
secrétaire d'État l'Europe le ministre
de Jersey edernez en pour évoquer toutes
ces questions des licences notamment à
la question des navires de remplacement
et donc nous sommes en bonne voie de
conclure un accord et de pouvoir être en
capacité de dire à tous les pêcheurs
qu'il avait demandé et bien qu'ils
pourront aller pêcher dans les îles
anglo-normandes
c'est pas terminé c'est pas
conclu c'est pas encore parapher mais en
tout cas il y a je crois un changement
de philosophie de la part du
gouvernement de Jersey et de Guernesey
qui me rend optimisme quand quand la
résolution
de ces problématiques qui se posaient à
nos pécheurs sur la question du terminal
du a vous l'avez évoqué mais c'est en
cours et semestre deuxième semestre 2023
tout ça sera lancé opérationnel ce qui
nous permettra là aussi de renforcer et
bien la capacité
d'approvisionnement de notre territoire
en énergie sur la question des migrants
monsieur le Président c'est un sujet qui
est
à la fois très sensible parce que ce
sont d'ailleurs chaque fois qu'il y a
des traversées il y a des vies humaines
donc il faut le faire avec
la plus grande rigueur et donc il y a un
travail très précis qui est mené avec le
ministère de l'intérieur avec la
préfecture maritime avec les préfets sur
l'action de l'État en mer pour à la fois
renforcer les moyens de l'État pour
justement faire face à cette
augmentation du nombre de traversées il
y a une action aussi diplomatique
européenne qui est mené notamment avec
l'Allemagne sur la question et bien des
navires des bateaux qui en général
partent de la même qui vont sur les
côtes françaises et donc là il y a un
travail diplomatique très fort qui est
mené par le ministre Gérald Dahmane et
puis un travail aussi sur les moyens
donnés à nos cross
notamment je pense au cross grindé là on
doit avoir une action de modernisation à
la fois dans les investissements des
cross et puis de renforcement des moyens
humains pour faire face justement
aux demandes de sauvetage et puis de
manière plus globale dans la politique
d'immigration c'est le texte qui sera
présenté d'avoir et bien tous les
dispositifs de modernisation et à la
fois
d'intégration la plus rapide possible et
en même temps de reconduite à la
frontière quand c'est nécessaire pour
l'immigrants que vous avez cité tout à
l'heure donc voilà sur la question de
des migrants on a on a bien conscience
que la situation elle est urgente on a
bien conscience aussi qu'il y a une
augmentation très forte des traversées
et donc nous mettons les moyens en face
monter en puissance progressive et nous
faisons ce travail diplomatique avec les
différents pays et notamment avec
l'Angleterre pour avoir un travail de
coopération le plus fin possible sur la
question du dumping social il y a trois
niveaux vous savez que le dumping social
fait partie aussi
de mes priorités parce que c'est un
enjeu à la fois de modèles social
français nous ne voulons pas avoir au
fond une spirale infernale qui se
développe dans le transmanche mais aussi
en Méditerranée avec comme ça a été le
cas par l'entreprise piéno le
licenciement brutal de plus de 800
marins remplacé par des marins au cou
très très faible parce que ça pose une
question aussi de sécurité
quand vous avez des marins qui font plus
de 20 semaines 100 jours de repos dans
le transmence avec bien évidemment les
les les les les la nécessité d'avoir une
vigilance de tous les instants nous
devons renforcer donc il y a trois
fonctions que nous avons sur la table 1
une charte d'engagement volontaire des
entreprises nous sommes en train de la
travailler sur le contenu la partie
anglaise est en discussion encore pour
savoir exactement ce qu'on met dedans en
tout cas nous avons eu à la table de
discussion de négociation piano
aeriferies nous avons annoncé que nous
souhaitions renforcer les dispositifs
législatifs et l'Assemblée nationale a
déposé une proposition de loi pour
justement lutter contre le dumping
social la semaine dernière donc il nous
donnera des moyens législatifs de
justement et bien empêcher des navires
qui ne correspondent pas aux modèles
sociaux français deux parties ou de
débarquer dans des ports français et
donc ça permettra et bien d'avoir un
standard entre les compagnies françaises
et les compagnies anglaises dans ce
transmanche nous allons travailler aussi
sur les enjeux de la Méditerranée qui
sont des enjeux différents puisque ce ne
sont pas des enjeux extra-communautaires
ce sont des enjeux au fond
intracommunautaire mais nous allons
aussi
le traité et puis nous allons travailler
aussi en coopération avec le
gouvernement anglais notamment la
ministre des Transports pour mettre la
pression maximale sur les entreprises
qui se livrent à ce dubbing social et
leur dire que ce n'est pas acceptable ça
par accepter et que nous allons
renforcer les contrôles nous avons déjà
renforcé les contrôles l'année dernière
nous allons continuer à le faire avec la
mise en place notamment d'une tasse
force interministérielle pour et bien
avoir des inspecteurs du travail avoir
des professionnels des affaires
maritimes qui multiplient les contrôles
et qui ne laisse rien passer sur ces
enjeux qui sont des enjeux
environnementaux de sécurité et de
modèles social
sur les enjeux madame la sénatrice qui
sont liées aux décharge littorales alors
ça c'est un sujet qui est moins traité à
mon ministère mais que nous avons bien
évidemment au sein du gouvernement
pleinement pris en charge il y a des
investissements que le Président de la
République avait annoncé que le
gouvernement également à lancer pour au
fond faciliter financer des
expérimentations sur le traitement de
ces décharges partout en outre-mer je
pourrais vous donner la liste plus
détaillée à l'issue de cette audition
sur les différents endroits où sont
lancés ces expérimentations mais en tout
cas nous allons continuer à investir
notamment avec le cerema pour aider les
communes pour bien porter des actions
très ambitieuses sur le traitement de
ces agents de littoral parce que c'est
un à la fois un enjeu d'équité
territorial puisque c'est souvent les
communes les plus pauvres qui n'ont pas
les moyens de traiter ça et c'est dans
ces communes les plus pauvres que se
retrouvent ces décharges et puis c'est
un enjeu aussi de de préservation de
l'environnement et donc nous allons
renforcer les moyens mais je pourrais
revenir vers vous avec les détails des
communes en tout cas c'est un sujet qui
est bien identifié dans le cas de
manière la plus large sur la question de
l'accompagnement des communes sur la
transition écologique et pour faire face
aussi à tout ce qui s'est passé depuis
des dizaines d'années en matière de
pollution notamment dans les territoires
ultramarins et c'est l'un des objectifs
aussi du fond vert qui a été lancé par
le Premier ministre c'est d'accompagner
toutes les initiatives locales et
d'accompagner la dépollution et le
lancement d'une stratégie de
décarbonation partout sur les
territoires sur le sujet madame
massénatrice que vous avez évoqué qui
était celui aussi des territoires
ultramarins au fond qu'elle ait la
stratégie il y a la question essentielle
de la modernisation de la flotte des
territoires ultramarins nous avons des
navires qui datent de 30 40 ans dans les
territoires ultramorrains c'est
inacceptable c'est inacceptable parce
que au fond et vous l'avez évoqué aussi
quand vous voyez qu'il y a des navires
d'autres pays
je suis très par exemple les navires
chinois mais il y a d'autres nations
aussi qui viennent dans les autres
territoriales françaises ou en tout cas
qui se livrent à des des parfois ce qui
s'apparente à du pillage des ressources
nous ne pouvons pas laisser les pêcheurs
de ces territoires je pense à Mayotte je
pense également à la Guyane je pense
aussi la Polynésie à la Réunion avec des
navires qui ne correspondent pas à la
pêche du XXe siècle donc il y a
malheureusement
en tout cas c'est une réalité
les règles de modernisation de la flotte
sont encadrées par des dispositifs
européens ça a été très compliqué
de faire bouger la commission sur ce
sujet en 2018 nous avons mis le pied
dans la porte nous ne sommes pas au bout
du combat il y a une ouverture qui a été
donnée par la commission sur un certain
nombre de territoires
ultramarins nous devons donner des
informations à la commission sur au fond
j'étais un peu technique mais sur
la question du maintien
des équilibres des segments c'est à dire
que la modernisation ne doit pas amener
à une capacité de pêche beaucoup plus
importante mais j'ai envie de dire c'est
évident puisqu'il y a des quotas donc
normalement la question de repas se
poser en tout cas nous avons des
informations que nous avons transmis à
la commission en 2022 elle nous a
redemandé des informations
supplémentaires nous attendons le retour
de la commission avec Jean-François
caraco nous avons porté un courrier
commun pour dire à quel point c'était
une urgence même une urgence politique
pour le service territoire à la parce
que si nous voulons attirer des jeunes
dans le métier on va pas leur demander
de faire la pêche du 21e siècle avec des
outils parfois du 19e siècle et donc
nous avons porté ce combat là avec
Jean-François caraco avec Laurence Boone
qui est allé aussi plaider la cause des
territoires ultramarins auprès des
différents commissaires et donc nous
avons bon espoir qu'en 2023 nous
commencerons à avoir les moyens et bien
d'investir dans le renouvellement de la
faute parce que la modernisation des
navires de flotte c'est un enjeu aussi
de décarbonation si on veut sortir de la
dépendance des navires au pétrole aux
indivis fossiles il faut décarboner pour
des carboner faut d'aborder et donc il
faut des nouvelles règles et donc c'est
ce que nous portons de manière très
forte sur l'enjeu qui est aussi lié au
fond c'est comment on permet le
développement d'une économie locale
d'une économie d'un ressource
halieutique dans le territoire
ultramarin il y a l'enjeu c'est un enjeu
de souveraineté de la lutte contre la
pêche illicite vous l'avez évoqué madame
la sénatrice et vous également le
président de la République m'a demandé
de mettre en oeuvre une stratégie de
lutte contre la pêche INN sont illicites
et non déclarés en lien avec le
secrétaire général à la mer en lien avec
la Marine nationale nous avons avec
Sébastien Lecornu porté de coopération
beaucoup plus forte avec les marines
européennes et avec les marines des pays
dans lequel nous sommes voisins dans les
territoires
ultramarins et donc en 2023 nous allons
déployer ces stratégies qui se fait à
trois niveaux 1 renforcer l'action de
l'État en mer des moyens supplémentaires
et des moyens qui sont adaptés au
territoire donc c'est pour ça que dans
le cadre de la loi de programmation
militaire que vous aurez à discuter nous
nous comptons beaucoup d'avoir justement
des moyens qui puissent être déployés
partout sur nos territoires ultramarins
et qui soit adapté à la lutte contre la
pêche illicite parfois c'est des navires
de taille importante parfois c'est des
plus petits navires pour pouvoir
justement dans les fleuves je pense à la
Guyane aller pour chasser ceux qui se
livrent à cette pièce illicite deuxième
élément c'est que l'Union européenne
prenne pleinement
possession de ses capacités vous l'avez
évoqué madame sénatrice de lutte contre
la pêche INN puisque c'est aussi une
compétence européenne donc ça veut dire
renforcer les sanctions c'est à dire
d'être en capsic de d'aller beaucoup
plus forte sur les questions de carton
rouge carton jaune pour les pays qui se
livrent à cette pêche inaine il y a un
carton jaune il me semble rouge qui a
été donné au Cameroun justement dans la
lutte contre la pêche illicite et puis
nous devons aussi faire en sorte que la
Commission européenne investissent
fortement dans des moyens et il nous
accompagne pour lutter contre la pêche
illicite dans les territoires
ultramarins et puis le dernier niveau
vous l'avez évoqué c'est le niveau
international les Américains les Anglais
font des choses mais ils sont pas
particulièrement en avance par rapport à
nous en tout cas ils ont lancé une
coalition internationale qui s'appelle
le
phishing que l'Union européenne souhaite
rejoindre pour justement mener des
actions de coopération au niveau
international mieux protéger la haute
mer tous ensemble et donc la France bien
évidemment est très sensible à cette
démarche et fera le maximum pour
renforcer la coopération et faire en
sorte qu'on a un cadre international
ambitieux pour lutter contre la pêche
illicite et faire en sorte que des
nations qui sont moins scrupuleuses sur
la protection de la ressource et bien
trop face à elle des nations qui sont à
la fois Unis soudées et qui mettent les
moyens sur le sujet là
je crois avoir répondu
cliquez sur
merci
[Musique]
on partage je dirais la même façade
maritime et la même région normande donc
on est à la fois intéressé par le
transport donc monsieur le ministre donc
Pascal Alizard donc a posé la question
de la différenciation de traitement
entre les différents ports sur les
moyens qui sont mis en œuvre par l'État
sur notamment les contrôles sanitaires
et les contrôles au sens large du terme
donc voilà
si on pouvait avoir une réponse et puis
en même temps je rebondis puisque vous
avez indiqué donc c'est vrai que le
dumping social sur le sur le transmence
donc est une question qui se pose avec
avec acuité vous avez mentionné donc le
licenciement massif des 800 salariés de
piano les parlementaires viennent de
déposer vous l'avez mentionné donc un
projet de loi donc le 31 avait une
proposition de loi le 31 janvier donc
une loi de police dans le cadre des
transports donc cette loi de police
stipule que que les dispositions légales
qui sont applicables aux salariés sur
les navires de transport de passagers
qui assurent des lignes régulières
internationales touchant les ports
français sont donc applicables aux
salariés du transmence dans les mêmes
conditions
de salaire minimum horaires est-ce que
vous allez soutenir avec des sanctions
pénales est-ce que vous allez soutenir
cette initiative parlementaire est-ce
que vous avez des réserves particulières
à faire sur sur cette proposition de loi
donc déposer le 31 janvier par les
députés je vous propose monsieur le
ministre de répondre aux deux en même
temps puisqu'ils avaient une question
commune et puis après on reprendra la
série des quatre
pardon monsieur le sénateur
j'étais parti loin dans les territoires
ultra périphériques
ultra marin d'ailleurs pas ultra
périphérique
sur l'enjeu au fond de
d'équilibrer aussi les compétences et
l'investissement avec les ports
décentralisés c'était le sens de votre
question nous avons avancé vous savez on
a donné les capacités supplémentaires au
port de Barneville et de Granville pour
justement et bien ce sujet de
réglementation d'angulation d'ailleurs
ça a été
apprécié par
Jersey et par Guernesey et donc c'est
dans le cadre de la statut national
portuaire et d'ailleurs
des élus de vos territoires de votre
territoire il me semble on participait
aussi à cette réunion du lancement de la
stratégie nationale portuaire où on va
justement regarder l'équilibre
territorial et donner des moyens
notamment contrôle vétérinaire enfin
tous les sujets que vous avez évoqués
pour que il n'y ait pas au fond ça me
permettait l'expression une
métropolisation des pores qui est pas
une concentration des richesses une
concentration des investissements une
concentration
de l'expertise que dans un certain type
de port c'est tout le sens de la
discussion que nous avons eu aussi aux
acides de l'économie de la mère à Lille
et c'est l'enjeu de déploiement de cette
stratégie nous avons essayé de le faire
au maximum dans le cadre du plan de
relance où on va essayer de d'investir
aussi pas simplement dans les grands
ports d'État en lien avec les régions
bien évidemment et avec aussi les
départements qui ont parfois la gestion
de ses ports en tout cas c'est un
travail que nous avons bien en tête
notamment parce que nous allons avoir à
faire face à des investissements massifs
notamment pour l'éolien en mer et c'est
maintenant qu'il faut réfléchir à la
stratégie à l'équilibre à la
distribution des compétences pour et
bien que tous les territoires soient
dynamisés par cette économie maritime
donc sur les points très précis si vous
avez sur des voilà des compétences
particulières dans des ports de votre
département je suis prêt à les regarder
mais en tout cas c'est le sens de
l'ouverture et de l'inflexion que j'ai
donné avec Barneville et Granville cette
année 2022
je n'ai pas travaillé que sur mon
département je tiens à le préciser et
les observations que j'ai eu c'est sur
l'ensemble du trait de côte sur les
ports qui ne sont pas des ports d'État
et j'attire votre attention sur
l'urgence de la situation parce que ça
crée des files d'attente et ça déporte
donc les clientèle
donc il y a un vrai problème de
concurrence ça fausse la concurrence
aussi
ça veut dire travailler fortement sur la
question d'usane
ça veut dire travailler fortement parce
que les pores sont des lieux industriels
or on vit une transition industrielle
avec la transition écologique avec la
décarbonation on sait dire aussi la
question des compétences c'est lié avec
les régions et c'est pour ça qu'on on
essaie de mettre d'aligner le maximum là
dans ces stratégies nationales
portuaires en réunissant pour la
première fois j'y insiste pour la
première fois des portes décentralisées
des grands ports d'État les
gestionnaires de port les mères les
régions les départements sont réunies
pour justement regarder comment on
investit intelligemment et de manière
équitable sur tout le territoire et donc
je se saisira
de la part de l'administration de votre
apport et à regarder précisément s'il y
a pas un certain nombre de dispositifs
qu'on peut déployer dès 2023 pour
assurer cet équilibre territoriale merci
Monsieur ministre sur la question de
Jean-Michel houlgats sans empiéter sur
le débat parlementaire à revenir il
posait une question assez précise sur la
PPL qui a été déposé
à l'Assemblée nationale sur le dumping
oui bien sûr non
nous la soutiendrons je la soutiens
en salut aux assises de l'économie de la
mer à Lille j'avais évoqué justement le
fait que si le Parlement souhaitait
saisir de cette question nous le
soutiendrons et donc Didier le gars qui
a proposé ce texte de loin qui a été
bien évidemment discuté avec mon
ministère en amont pour voir quels
étaient nous aussi un certain nombre de
priorités qui nous paraissaient
essentiel et donc nous soutiendrons ce
texte de loin avec la volonté qui soit
appliquée le plus rapidement possible
parce que c'est à la fois une question
de signal politique j'avais évoqué des
mesures législatives en novembre 2022
nous sommes en janvier et une PPL qui
est déposée donc merci beaucoup au
Parlement merci beaucoup à vous de vous
êtes aussi engagé dans cette dynamique
collective et de notre côté aussi sur la
question des contrôles sur la question
des sanctions nous sommes au rendez-vous
et en tout cas nous mènerons cette
action en parallèle donc nous
soutiendrons ce texte et j'espère qu'il
ça au Sénat le plus rapidement possible
merci allez quatre questions pour
terminer quatre prises de parole
Christine lavard Didier Marie Jacques
Pernic et Patricia Schillinger dans cet
ordre Christine oui merci monsieur le
ministre je vous ai écouté avec
attention et je vous ai surtout entendu
parler d'initiative française et assez
peu d'initiative partagée pour autant la
mer est quand même un endroit où il n'y
a pas de frontière enfin si on pense par
exemple à la pollution si nous on est ou
à la protection des océans si on est
très attentif sur notre littoral les
courants marins eux ils vont partout et
si nos voisins anglais ne font pas la
même chose enfin on perd tout et donc je
pense notamment à un espace fermé la
Méditerranée où il y a des enjeux très
forts de biodiversité il y a aussi des
enjeux touristiques donc comment est-ce
que vous vous placez avec nos
partenaires européens les Espagnols les
Italiens demain les Croates les Grecs
pour voilà c'est un exemple exemple mais
pour préserver cet espace et ce que vous
pouvez nous dire là où nous avons des
alliés sur quelle politique et où là où
nous avons un certain nombre de
difficultés à nous faire entendre
Didier Didier merci président monsieur
le ministre moi je suis aussi élu de
Normandie donc je partage des questions
qui ont pu être posées par
mes collègues tout comme celle du
président sur les hauts de France
vous avez répondu globalement j'aurais
juste une question complémentaire je
voudrais savoir ce qu'il en est du
différent qui opposait la France et les
Pays-Bas quand la présence de navires
usine
en manche qui venait détériorer les
fonds marins et capter l'essentiel de la
pêche
j'aurais revenir sur la question de la
Chine
que ma collègue martinrak a abordé la
flotte européenne c'est 259 navires
hauturiers la flotte chinoise
aujourd'hui c'est 2700 et donc le
problème à mon avis mérite une
intervention extrêmement
urgente car les chinois sont en train de
piller les fonds marins au large de
l'Afrique dans l'océan bien et ceci ne
peut se faire sans une réaction
internationale et une réaction d'Union
Européenne beaucoup plus rapide que
celle que vous avez mentionnées enfin
troisième question le 17 janvier il y a
une résolution de l'Assemblée nationale
sur la protection des fonds marins
visant à interdire une exploitation non
maîtrisée des minerais qui se trouvent
au fond de nos océans et je voudrais
savoir qu'il a position du Gouvernement
sur ce sujet et quelle suite elle
souhaite donner à la résolution de
l'Assemblée nationale merci Didier
Jacques
merci président merci de vos
explications monsieur le ministre donc
deux sujets le premier donc pour
rebondir sur ce qui évoquait Didier
marie à l'instant donc on sur la
question de l'exploitation minière ou
non des grands fonds marins là-dessus je
suis je suis satisfait que le
gouvernement est bien évolué il y a eu
la mobilisation des ONG il y a eu le
texte récent de l'Assemblée nationale
je crois que ce qui est intéressant
c'est que plus que qu'un simple
moratoire notre exécutif par la voix
d'ailleurs du président de la République
s'est engagé à interdire cette
exploitation minière donc la question
désormais c'est
la façon de réussir à convaincre déjà
les autres pays européens encore
réticents à rejoindre cet élan donc
comment comptez-vous agir pousser au
conseil pour que notre position prospère
et qu'elle obtienne des résultats
concrets mon autre question c'est celle
qui a pas encore été évoqué je crois de
la protection des dauphins donc dossier
que vous connaissez on a des centaines
de dauphins qui chaque année se
retrouvaient échoués sur les plages de
l'Atlantique un phénomène bien documenté
par les ONG les scientifiques sur
lesquels ils alertent depuis près de 30
ans ça 16 de s'amplifier on voit encore
que récemment il y a encore des alertes
là-dessus importantes la responsabilité
elle est identifiée c'est la pêche
industrielle avec des dauphins capturés
accidentellement par des engins et qui
sont rejetés à l'eau mutilés pour finir
sur les plages c'est un contexte
permissif qui permet à cette ces impacts
de perdurer la France a déjà été
condamné pour surmortalité c'est assez
sur la face Atlantique notamment par le
tribunal administratif de Paris les
solutions elles sont identifiées je
crois que c'est de l'ordre des alarmes
sonores des fermetures temporelles de
pêche aux périodes de reproduction donc
comment mettre réussir à se mettre en
conformité avec le droit européen la
directive habitale réglement
mésotechnique je crois qu'il y a eu une
un courrier de la Commission européenne
qui donnait deux mois cet été à la
France pour se mettre à niveau pour
empêcher les prises accessoires de
cétacés
donc comment avancer clairement
là-dessus pour éviter de se faire
condamner par la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne
merci Jacques Patricia
Hervé il y a un sujet dont on parle peu
mais qui est quand même assez
flagrant et qui nous impacte tous et la
guerre des conteneurs le trafic maritime
et est en stand-bye depuis de 3 ans
depuis la crise du covid et on depuis
disons l'année dernière que 35% donc de
de de navire arriver à temps et en heure
dans les dans les ports européens
beaucoup de navires étaient en stand-by
vraiment moi j'ai vu une émission
c'était flagrant de voir autant de
navires en mer en stand by parce qu'il
n'avait pas de boulot entre guillemets
est-ce que on n'en sait plus est-ce
qu'on a avancé parce que c'est aussi
polluant de rester en mer et pas
peut-être
dans un port et ce qui nous impacte
aussi c'est ben justement l'importation
la Chine ne pouvait pas exporter parce
qu'il y avait un manque de conteneur
donc savoir si vous pouvez en dire un
peu plus et comment se fait le contrôle
parce que ben il y a les États-Unis il y
a c'est un peu non dans toutes ces mers
là donc ou océan en tout cas merci pour
les réponses que vous pouvez nous
apporter
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs sur
les questions de Madame lavardde alors
je vais peut-être un peu moins vécu
parce que les il y avait des questions
aussi qui tournaient plutôt sur les
initiatives françaises mais bien
évidemment tout ça sur tous les plans
nous ne pouvons pas résoudre les
solutions les problèmes pardon si vous
n'avaient pas des solutions européennes
ou de coopération internationales c'est
l'évoquer avec la question de la lutte
contre la pêche illicite d'abord sur la
question de la pollution c'est également
par exemple la question de comment on
porte au niveau international sur par
exemple la question des pollutions et
des pertes de conteneur c'est une action
qu'on porte la France portraitsolument
au niveau de l'Organisation maritime
internationale sur la question de la
réduction des émissions du secteur on le
porte aussi au niveau international et
c'est avec des initiatives européennes
des initiatives portées avec un certain
nombre de pays que nous arrivons à et
bien à atteindre nos objectifs et à ce
aussi à se doter d'une politique
multilatérale qui à la fois ambitieuse
efficace et qui secondes aux enjeux que
vous avez parfaitement décrit sur la
Méditerranée je donnais quelques
exemples nous avons mis en place une
zone
[Musique]
CK sur la limitation du soufre c'est une
initiative avec d'autres pays
partenaires dans le cadre du traité de
Barcelone que la France et l'Espagne ont
signé ensemble sur la question de au
fond de la protection de la Méditerranée
tout ça se fait avec les pays du
pourtour Méditerrané pour lutter contre
et bien la pollution pour là aussi
réduire la vitesse des navires pour
réduire les risques de collision avec
aussi les cétacés pour faire en sorte de
mettre en plus de place pardon une zone
NECA sur
là aussi des micros aux pollution bref
toute l'action en Méditerranée se fait
avec l'Italie avec l'Espagne avec les
pays également du Maghreb et que c'est
une action qui est résolument européenne
et sur le dumping social par exemple je
me suis rendu à Madrid c'était en
novembre pour justement là aussi
convaincre nos partenaires espagnols de
s'engager dans la lutte contre le
dumping social parce que eux aussi
commencent à voir le développement et
bien de pratiques
de pratique on dire qui qui sont
répréhensibles ou en tout cas qui nous
souhaitons pas avoir prospérer sur leur
code avec mon homologue italien nous
travaillons aussi également à de
l'action sur la décarbonation ils ont
lancé un plan sur la décarbonation des
navires et du transport maritime italien
et donc nous faisons en pleine
coopération sur la question la plus
quotas nous travaillons aussi parce que
nous avons mené une coalition où il y a
ces pays européens bref toute l'action
maritime parce que vous l'avez très bien
elle touche par définition d'autres pays
parce que la France a la chance d'être
dans tous les continents dans toutes les
mers grâce à son espace maritime se fait
en pleine coopération et nous allons
continuer de le faire et ça me permet de
rebondir sur les deux questions qui ont
été évoquées par le sénateur Marie et
Fernique sur par exemple l'interdiction
de l'exploitation minière des grands
fonds marins je crois que c'est une
décision prise par le Président de la
République à la cop27 à sharm-elcher en
Égypte qui est historique et aussi
courageuse historique dans le sens où
c'est nous sommes le premier pays à nous
positionner non pas simplement pour une
pose de précaution c'est à dire on
attend de voir quels seraient les
impacts éventuels de l'exploitation
minière pour pouvoir dire si oui ou non
nous y allons ni même un moratoire qui
vise au fond à repousser un peu les
échanges mais le président de la
République a été très clair en disant il
n'y aura pas d'exploitation minière des
grands fonds marins dans les eaux
françaises ni aujourd'hui ni demain et
nous allons nous battre en créant des
coalitions pour que cette position
devienne une position prioritaire dans
les différentes instances nous le
faisons parce que je crois que tout le
monde a désormais conscience que l'océan
et les grands fonds marins sont des
espaces qui sont fragiles sont
importants dans la régulation du climat
et recèle d'une biodiversité qui pour
l'instant n'a pas été encore touché par
des activités humaines particulièrement
polluantes donc faisons en sorte de les
préserver et donc pour répondre à la
question de Monsieur Marie le
gouvernement a donné un avis très
favorable à la résolution des députés
puisque le président trois mois avant
l'occasion de se positionner pour une
interdiction d'exploitation minière des
fonds marins ils avaient moi même eu
l'occasion au Sénat devant
une devant la la
la mission d'information sur justement
l'exploration et l'exploitation des
fonds marins avec un rapport notamment
du sénateur tevarochere une grande
qualité d'expliquer la position de la
France et notamment d'annoncer la Fin du
financement d'un démonstrateur qui
visait justement à faire de
l'exploitation minière des fonds marins
en disant que la France désormais se
tournerait uniquement vers l'exploration
la connaissance à la recherche
scientifique et donc nous allons
déployer dans le cadre de France 2030 un
plan de 350 millions d'euros pour
l'exploration la recherche la
connaissance scientifique de ces grands
fonds marins qui sont des espaces
remarquables et pour répondre à la
question de Monsieur Fernique sur la
stratégie à mener désormais elle est à
trois niveaux un politique continuait à
convaincre notamment les pays de l'Union
européenne que c'est la voie à suivre
en le faisant avec bien évidemment toute
l'humilité nécessaire en comprenant que
il y a d'autres pays qui ont peut-être
des intérêts des enjeux différents en
disant que si on veut faire face aux
enjeux qui sont devant nous n'avons pas
le choix je crois que d'aller dans ce
sens là et c'est à dire de de
d'interdire c'est ce type d'activité et
surtout que nous n'avons pas besoin de
ça pour faire face à la transition
énergétique il y a un rapport très bien
fait de WF qui montre que nous avons pas
besoin de ces métaux dans les grands
fonds marins pour répondre notamment aux
enjeux industriels et c'est la raison
pour laquelle les entreprises comme BMW
des entreprises aussi d'autres secteurs
ce sont prononcés
pour le fait de ne jamais utiliser des
métaux issus de l'exploitation des fonds
marins donc nous allons continuer à
porter le combat politique je me suis
rendu
à la COP 15 pour bien évidemment parler
des sujets de protection de la
biodiversité des océans mais aussi pour
faire en sorte que dans le texte de la
Coop 15 il y a des éléments de sur
l'exploitation minière des fonds marins
et donc pour la première fois nous avons
des éléments alors c'est pas exactement
ce que l'on souhaitait totalement mais
c'est la première fois qu'il est mis
qu'il faut faire preuve de précaution
dans
l'exploitation des fonds marins et ça
c'est une négociation qu'on a réussi à
trouver tous ensemble avec ce portage
politique
du président de la République mais aussi
de pays comme le Costa Rica le Chili
l'Espagne qui avec qui nous avons formé
une coalition à la COP 15 je me rendrai
à New York fin février pour le traiter
sur la haute mer et là aussi j'aurai
l'occasion de continuer à faire ce
travail de plaidoyer pour convaincre le
maximum de pays de nous rejoindre c'est
travailler politique et un travail
juridique nous travaillons en
franco-allemand pour justement
déterminer les outils juridiques les
plus adaptés pour empêcher en juillet
2023 d'avoir au fond une licence qui
autoriserait une entreprise à pouvoir
commencer à exploiter les fonds marins
donc ça c'est un travail juridique que
l'on nous faisons avec notamment nos
partenaires allemands j'ai l'occasion de
de la rencontrer à la COP 15 et de
Regine tribune commune appelant à
un moratoire une pose de précaution à
l'interdiction d'exploitation des fonds
marins et puis il y aura un travail au
sein de la IFM l'autorité internationale
sur les fonds marins où je crois que
nous devons convaincre le maximum de
pays que cet instant ce qui a été créé
dans les années 90 qui est su de la
Convention des droits de la mer et qui
visait à l'époque à une gestion durable
de l'exploitation minière de format doit
je crois changer réorienter son mandat
pour un mandat de protection la
biodiversité un mandat de connaissance
de recherche et donc l'ambassadeur
Olivier pour avoir ses rendus à la
demande du président et la mienne en
juillet pour porter expliquer la voix de
la France et nous aurons l'occasion de
continuer à le faire donc voilà niveau
politique niveau juridique mais
également en termes de recherche
scientifique et de financement de la
connaissance et puis sur les dauphins
monsieur le sénateur Fernique
la France en effet a été condamné par
l'Union européenne et donc nous allons
mis en place un plan d'urgence en
septembre un plan d'urgence ambitieux
pour faire face justement à ces quatre
accidentelles de cétacé ce plan
d'urgence il a plusieurs éléments un un
équipement obligatoire comme des
dispositifs de localisation des
farrangements et de caméra vidéo
et donc moi j'ai handicap plusieurs
reprises que ces caméras vidéo seraient
mise en oeuvre de nous avons
identifié les danses navires les plus
actifs et nous travaillons avec elle et
donc il n'y avait que 20 de ces navires
qui étaient équipés de caméras il y en
aura désormais 100 et donc nous
déployons ce plan là les délais sont
tenus il y a des passations de marché
qui sont en cours il y a des
investissements conséquents de l'État
qui sont nous travaillons avec des
scientifiques avec l'Office français de
la biodiversité pour mettre en oeuvre ce
plan en tirer toutes les conséquences
avoir des des données de l'acquisition
de connaissances et ensuite et bien
faire en sorte de réduire et de ne pas
avoir ces images qui bien évidemment et
meuf tout le monde de dauphin échouer
mutilés et donc la profession les
pêcheurs et je voulais ici saluer aussi
Olivier Nezet ce sont pleinement saisies
de ce sujet là nous aussi nous
travaillons avec la secrétaire d'État
chargée de la biodiversité Bérengère
kouyard pour déployer mettre en œuvre et
investir dans ce plan de lutte contre la
capture accidentelle des stacée
et pardon
sur la la question des conteneurs
l'objectif qui a été défini dans le
principe dans quinquennat c'est de
porter de 60 à 80 % la part des ports
français dans le total des conteneurs
débarqués
au départ ou en France et donc c'est
tout l'enjeu qui a été fait avec
notamment un repas le fait d'investir
dans les grands ports d'État mais aussi
à travers la stratégie nationale
portuaire dès qu'il est partout sur les
territoires la question que vous posez
c'est une question qui est une question
de souveraineté c'est au fond
d'équilibre et maîtriser flux c'est une
question aussi de formation et bien des
agents qui travaillent de recrutement
dans cette filière et donc nous aurons à
continuer à déployer développer une
stratégie notamment sur le pavillon
français pour et bien avoir une part des
conteneurs français qui augmentent des
ports qui sont adaptés avec des
investissements qui sont faits et les
investissements qui sont devant nous ils
sont massifs sur la différence sur les
les grands ports d'État et donc nous
travaillons avec Clément Beaune pour je
continue à mettre en oeuvre aussi des
rapports qui ont été faits ici des très
bons rapports du du sénateur sur au fond
la réduction de nos dépendances à
d'autres ports notamment à les ports du
Nord de la France du Nord européen en
verse Rotterdam et autres et donc nous
aurons l'occasion à travers la
satinationale portuaire la deuxième
réunion que nous tiendrons avec Clément
bonne en mars de continuer à déployer
les différents investissements et la
stratégie que nous souhaitons et nous
regardons ça bien évidemment de la
manière la plus rigoureuse la plus
ambitieuse possible en lien avec les
territoires parce que désormais je crois
que les régions les départements ont
aussi nous l'avons évoqué dans les
Hauts-de-France ont à cœur de participer
pleinement au développement de
l'économie maritime et donc d'investir
quand c'est possible dans les les
activités portuaires
merci monsieur le ministre et sans
remettre dessous dans la musique c'est
aussi un sujet d'usane l'extension
merci monsieur le ministre de toutes ces
réponses je pense que c'est une audition
qui aura duré presque 1h30 mais elle
aurait pu endurer trois
vous dire aussi que voilà on attend
aussi avec impatience les premiers
retours des discussions avec avec les
Suédois on en reparlera pas peut-être
qu'elle est quel est leur vision
durant durant leur président et puis
celle des Espagnols dans la foulée parce
qu'on va arriver à des échéances
européennes proches
et puis et puis on parlera peut-être à
nouveau lors d'une autre audition de la
relation avec la Commission et notamment
du commissaire à la pêche pour savoir
quelles sont ses intentions qui ont été
un peu chahutées au début de son mandat
par rapport à la vision française mais
en tout cas et à la pêche artisanale
mais on sait très bien ici vous avez des
fervent défenseurs autour de cette table
de pêche artisanale en tout cas
important pour les territoires
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci à vous
et merci de l'action résolu pour notre
ambition